Let's see, where do we want to go next?
Uh Oh, I don't know.
Let's go.
Let's go to mark from Newport who we haven't
heard from, uh, for several months.
Mark from what's going on today.
Hey David, thanks for taking my call.
In your progressive sense self-censorship
video.
When you were discussing Israel, you had mentioned
that you oppose the right wing, that Yahoo
government where I completely agree, you had
mentioned that you support is really withdrawal
from the West Bank where I completely agree,
but you also mentioned that you supported
complete his well Israeli withdrawal from
eastern Islam.
And I was just wondering if you could explain
that a bit more.
Oh, so it's a little more nuanced than that,
but I didn't, you know, the segment wasn't
fully about that.
So the, the scenario I envision as from a
pragmatic perspective leading to real prospects
for an agreement to be done.
And this is of course like assuming we can
even get to negotiations, which we're nowhere
near being able to get to.
I envisioned that to get agreement for a two,
two state solution east Jerusalem would become
a part of the Palestinian Territories.
But within that Israel would retain control
of the Jewish quarter of the old city.
I see that as pretty non negotiable.
So it's a little more nuance than I said in
that segment.
That's probably how I would imagine it working
out.
Okay.
That, that makes it a bit more sense.
What about specific, um, specifically control
inside the temple?
Now I know we've both, uh, we've both been
there and I've heard you tell your story about
visiting, about going inside on the show.
What do you think that should, um, what do
you think should be the case with the status
of control inside the Temple Mount, which
right now is under the under control of the
lockers?
Yeah.
I think that it is going to be very difficult
to, again, I'm thinking pragmatically, I don't
know how you um, don't leave control over
the Temple Mount, um, to, you know, whether
it's Jordanian authorities or what become
Palestinian authorities.
It just seems like that is going to be a sticking
point in any serious negotiation.
I just, I don't know how Israel even justifies
taking control back of it.
Sure.
And then my last question super quick was
a lot of progressive's as I'm sure you've
heard, um, are increasingly supporting a one
state, um, a one-state democracy as a solution
for the conflict, which to me sounds far you
to your toe at Utopian is something I could
even take seriously.
Just being familiar with it.
I know the dynamics on the ground there.
Yeah.
I was curious your view on just uh, on a binational
democracy.
Yup.
I support a two state solution.
Is it full stop?
Could you end, would you entertain it at all?
I mean, listen, I, I will entertain anything.
If someone wants to bring to me a one state
solution that would not be subject to all
of the problems of all of the other one state
solution ideas that we've seen so far, I will
entertain it.
But as of right now, I support a two state
solution period.
Okay.
I that, that's where I'm at as well.
I support the two state solution, uh, period
and, but I keep hearing the, I just keep hearing
one state solution, um, rhetoric more and
more and more on the left, understandably.
But it just seems to, um, to a Farfetch to
me, but hey, uh, thank you very much for taking
my call today.
All right, mark from Newport.
Great to hear from you.